y desde la costa oeste de francia partió
la avant de glof la tradicional regata
que consiste en dar la vuelta al mundo
en vela en solitario sin escalas ni
asistencias- en la esap dolón nuestra
periodista natalia ruiz presenció la
largada y nos cuenta más con cerca de
una hora y 40 minutos de retraso salió
finalmente la donde globe esta carrera
en barco en el solitario sin escalas y
sin asistencia para darle la vuelta a la
mundo salió desde aquí desde les habló
de dolón sobre el atlántico francés por
causa del confinamiento puede ser las
miles de personas que normalmente salen
a dar a despedir a estos héroes a estos
navegantes no pudieron hacerlo pero
estuvieron presentes desde las ventanas
y desde los balcones de sus casas con
vítores con pitos con pancartas muchos
aplausos y también una que otra lágrima
vimos en los ojos de estos aventureros
30 y 36 de ellos son mujeres la primera
vez que hay tantas mujeres que
participan en esta carrera y bueno pues
les espera este recorrido de 45 mil
kilómetros pasando por el cabo de buena
esperanza atravesando el temible océano
índico
hasta llegar a la cabo de hornos esa es
la salida de la puerta de salida de la
gran sur para llegar aquí hasta el
establo de dolor una vez más dos
objetivos el primero terminar la carrera
porque en promedio sólo la mitad logran
cruzar la línea de llegada y el segundo
pues romper el récord conseguido por
arma nuclear en la edición pasada hace
cuatro años de 74 días 3 horas y 35
minutos algo que va a ser bastante
factible porque este año hay cada vez
más barcos que vienen con of fighters
unos apéndices a babor y estribor que
permiten prácticamente navegar como
volar por encima de la agua por ahora
pues las condiciones climáticas de la
salida más allá de la bruma en realidad
fueron bastante favorables pero ya en la
noche del lunes al martes tendrán que
enfrentar la primera depresión